can we talk a little bit about the drake  equation  so another framework from which to have  this kind of discussion about  uh possible civilizations out there so  let me ask  within the context of the drake equation  or maybe bigger how many  alien civilizations do you think are out  there well it's hard to tell because the  drake equation is again quantifying our  ignorance it's just  a set of factors the only one  that we know are actually two that we  know quite well is  the rate of star formation in the milky  way galaxy which we  measured by now and the  frequency of planets like the earth  around stars yes  and at the right distance to have life  but  other than that there are lots of  implicit  assumptions about all the other factors  that will enable us to detect a signal  now i should say the drake equation has  a very limited validity just for  signals from civilizations that are  transmitting at the time that you're  observing them  you